gilbert roger sénateur socialiste de
seine-saint-denis et vice président de
la commission des affaires étrangères
gilbert roger merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france on a entendu des
manifestants témoignaient avec des
paroles comme celle ci des violences
policières
ancré dans notre société en france des
violences policières raciste est ce que
vous partagez ce constat vous l'homme
politique je crois c'est peut-être dans
les expressions un peu excessif mais il
faut rester toujours attentif à ce que
notre démocratie soit exemplaire donc
notre police et notre justice nous mêmes
les élus nous devons l'être
et souvent quand des jeunes étudiants
collégiens lycéens et collez les mantais
reviennent visiter lé sénat
systématiquement je leur fais voir le
buste de victor schoelcher je leur fais
voir la place où il siégeait au sein de
l'hémicycle et je leur rappelle que
c'est ici au sénat que nous avions aboli
l'esclavagé et donc nous sommes dans une
société dans laquelle le droit le
respect doit être le doivent être
absolument notre ligne de conduite
alors vous êtes vous et moi je lisais
sénateur de seine-saint-denis un
département qui fait souvent l'actualité
notamment il a eu cette histoire de
gabriel ce jeune de 14 ans arrêté par la
police à suez une tentative voilà de vol
et de scooters il a été gravement blessé
à l'oeil lors de son interpellation
est ce que les policiers sont ils
vraiment bien préparé à travailler dans
des zones urbaines sensibles selon vous
je pense qu'il manque toujours de la
préparation j'ai très longtemps était le
maire de bondy et souvent je je
considérais qu'avec
le commissaire la commissaire de police
avoir des rencontres et des temps
important de parole notamment avec les
nouveaux arrivants dans le commissariat
était quelque chose d'important pour
qu'ils comprennent
là où ils allaient exercer leur
difficile métier c'est un problème de
dialogue peut-être ce que vous nous
dites entre entre la police et la
jeunesse aujourd'hui des quartiers
sensibles
oui parce que souvent notre jeunesse a
le sentiment d'être laissés pour compte
c'est regarder ne serait-ce qu jeudi
après midi
il a fallu que ce soit l'elysée un
colloque qui rencontre l'ensemble des
forces vives de la nation avec le
président de la république pour faire
qu'à la rentrée scolaire des apprentis
des jeunes étudiants puissent trouver
capacité à faire ce stage pour être
intégré dans à la fois dans
l'enseignement mais aussi dans le
pratique d'une entreprise qu'est ce que
vous voulez quand vous êtes jeunes que
vous passé des années à essayer
d'apprendre et que vous sentez que les
chefs d'entreprise ne sont pas tous
ouverts open comme ils disent à leur
recrutement
et bien vous sentez mal et c'est ça qui
est inadmissible
qu'est ce qu'ils vous disent vos
administrés que vous vous côtoyer
régulièrement en seine-saint-denis par
rapport à cette question de violences
policières et de racisme quels sont les
retours que vous avez je crois que sur
les retours nous savons souvent ils le
disent il n'y a pas assez de policiers
et ils ne sont pas intégrés dans la
commune
on est passé d'une police dite de
proximité
moi j'ai connu ça comme élu local avec
ce qu'ils appelaient jean pierre
chevènement la police du quartier dans
le quartier discutant avec les gardiens
gardienne d'immeuble avec les
commerçants avec les jeunes à une police
qui est tellement éloigné qu'elle ne
vient quand il ya des coups à faire coup
c'est à dire appel à urgence ce qui a
été le cas à bondy c'est parce qu'ils
aient eu un appel en urgence parce que
le jeune gabriel est un de ses amis
était en train de voler un scooter que
une brigade est arrivée de jeunes 16 ou
et excès confrontation lieu
donc il faut revenir à une police qui
soient intégrés dans la société et c'est
ce que l'on voit aux états unis c'est la
grande différence qu'il y a où la police
est absente du dialogue civil est donc
délibérément se permet de maltraiter une
partie de la population en particulier
la population noire américaine
et est ce que vous constatez également
en france du côté de la police à manque
de moyens qui pourraient expliquer les
difficultés des policiers à exercer
sereinement leur mission mais bien sûr
combien d'élus locaux dénoncent eux la
petitesse des moyens peu de voitures peu
d'équipement et puis nous le voyons
malheureusement très peu de policiers et
avec une expérience limite limité sur le
travail de terrain
ce qui est dommageable en particulier
dans les quartiers populaires alors pour
conclure
autre interrogation beaucoup de
manifestations ces derniers jours alors
que elles sont interdites à cause de la
crise sanitaire l'état d'urgence de
crise d'état d'urgence sanitaire comment
etc c'est ce que vous expliquez
finalement le gouvernement n'ait pas
réussi à faire respecter l'interdiction
de manifester c'est très compliqué
l'événement américain est un événement
désormais planétaire et en plus
regardons c'est incompréhensible de la
part du président des états unis enfin
monsieur trompe il disqualifié dans ses
tweets vengeurs et ravageur et donc que
je ne vois pas pourquoi un gouvernement
comme la france ou d'autres pays parce
que en europe et dans le monde tout le
monde réagit on a vu le geste symbolique
du premier ministre canadien
et oui on aurait peut être pu avoir le
geste du président ou du premier
ministre de la france sache n'ayant lui
aussi pour marquer ce témoignage de
solidarité avec une communauté
américaine noire américaine qui s'est
sentie exclue complètement de la société
civile américaine
merci beaucoup gilles roger d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes sénateur socialiste de
seine-saint-denis et vice président de
la commission des affaires étrangères